this year we hosted the first iteration
of a physics and Consciousness
explication challenge this is where
brilliant.org pitched in 1000 USD to
each of the top five entries totaling
five thousand dollars we received such a
rich volume of explanatory videos from
you which were designed to Showcase
theories explanations rigorous
expository material in general as to
what lies at the fundaments of our
reality entrants were encouraged to go
over a theory of their own or to expand
either an application or the details of
a theory that they were particularly
fond of in the last two months there's
been a market increase in the attention
to a wide variety of small channels due
to this challenge considering that the
vast majority of the entrants were
uploaded to nascent channels where the
entry was among the first or the second
videos uploaded it warmed my heart it
still warms my heart that such an
extensive amount of people chose to take
part in this again the point of this
challenge isn't to win what the heck
does winning mean anyway but instead to
serve as encouragement for those who are
on the periphery of wanting to produce
content in this space but lack that last
modicum of a nudge in order to evaluate
the entries as a first pass we ran a
peer review process where an algorithm
would feed participants different videos
to compare and they'd be asked to vote
on which one more aptly fits the
criteria about to be listed as well as
their own preference there are so many
entries I thought maybe 10 people would
partake in this I remember telling
brilliant like this is going to be not
terribly successful it's a test it's an
experiment we like to innovate a toll on
most of what's inventive or attempts to
be inventive or most of what's new fails
at its first attempt second even third
however we received over 50 submissions
superlative submissions they were well
constructed they were engaging clearly
the videos took an arduous amount of
work like geez Louise thus we firstly
and formlessly thank everyone for all
the work that they put in and while we
did promise to select five winners hey
this sounds so cheesy but you all are
winners there's a playlist on the
channel right now where you can go and
you can look at all the entries to
choose winners Sam and I both spent
several weeks giving a thorough look at
the entries this was after the peer
review process and we also recruited
other researchers and academics who are
in the relevant field to help make that
decision and by the way there will be
plenty more of these contests these
challenges these encouragements to help
further the understanding of mathematics
Consciousness physics theories of
everything in general this is just the
beginning let's get on to the criteria
one of the goals was to create an
atmosphere conducive to innovation
without becoming stymied by various
factors we wanted to highlight the
fields and the ideas and the top five
entries are less about winning and more
about clearly demonstrating a capacity
to explain Concepts have fun while doing
so and make it fun for the audience as
well the first Criterion was a
complexity to clearness ratio it'd be
great if we had something that was
extremely complex explained extremely
clearly the second was we encouraged
Advanced topics and the third was the
video's engaging characteristics so this
is much more of a subjective
consideration we intended to keep in the
filmmaker's term of production value and
look for it to be high or medium to high
that is 4K or 1080p proper sound edited
moderately well and we have to modulo
that with knowing that this is some of
the entry's first video that they're
producing the fourth was rigor such that
the presentation was not hand wavy
there's an encouragement of the use of
diagrams and logic and cogency equations
they were prioritized in fact Fifth and
finally was the ah I see Factor this is
the aspect of some explainers where you
know where you want to end up so point B
is explained and point a is where you
start then you have some route and often
it's circuitous but then the different
elements line up such that by the end
you say ah okay I see I understand now
let us begin with the honorable mentions
first up is the ctmu in five questions
by just here for Theo the cognitive
theoretic model of the universe is a
philosophical theory developed by Chris
Langan the ctm new posits that the
universe is a self-contained
self-generating system of thought and
experience in that reality can be
understood as a comprehensive closed
system of all and only that which is
real the theory asserts the feedback is
the invariant principle of reality and
that reality has a scalable ontology
implying the presence of a fundamental
order the ctmu also integrates various
branches of knowledge including
mathematics physics metaphysics and
philosophy into a coherent unified
worldview the ultimate aim of the ctmu
is to provide a comprehensive
understanding of reality that
encompasses all that is real and
explains the relationship between
Consciousness thought in the universe
the system is characterized by a sense
of closure and demonstrates the idea
that reality has a scalable ontology the
author presents a clear and easy to
follow exploration of the premise
leading to a well-articulated conclusion
regularity in non-standard models of
arithmetic by Nicholas Nicholas seated
regally with the radiant neon heart as
his backdrop delves into the Axiom of
foundation in standard set theory
offering a fresh perspective by
revisiting it as a rule that governs
sets which exclude themselves he then
builds upon this Foundation along with
piano arithmetic to explore the
Practical applications of arithmetic
induction in his insightful examination
nicholish posits that minimal element
statements correspond to a principle
that underscores the interconnectedness
of all systems and set theory is the key
to understanding these connections after
meticulous deliberation the author
presents a comprehensive and easily
digestible conclusion centered around a
non-standard model of physics rooted in
piano arithmetic
how I stumbled upon the best Theory of
Everything yet by the means of
Destruction in this video the
intricacies of the hyperbolic Figure 8
knot in its complement are meticulously
dissected a guest on the show with an
intuition reminiscent of Einstein offers
a geometric solution to the elusive fine
structure constant these findings have
been verified through independent
research efforts shedding light on the
previously unknown Realms of scientific
advancement
an interconnected system of energy by
hussam Wadi the articles in question
delve into a conceptual framework of
energy intriguing and worthy of
consideration these imaginative models
underpinned by a modest degree of
mathematical intuition and a testable
hypothesis hold the potential to enhance
our comprehension of reality this series
aspires to Foster foundation for
exploratory musings through a sequence
of hypothetical exercises and thought
experiments rather than offering a
comprehensive set of formal proofs
utilizing techniques and methods
commonly found in the development of
robotic systems this paper Endeavors to
unravel the intricacies of reality the
illumination of the projections of light
suggests the existence of a cosmic
camera obscura which can be modeled
using a pinhole camera Matrix this
enables us to examine the structure
through an alternative perspective and
relate the layers of light projections
to a deep restricted boltzmann Network
representation of quantum information
toe for Kurt by Alexi Alexi guides us
through a captivating journey of nine
books each delving into a different
aspect of Consciousness and reality he
covers topics ranging from influence in
space and the liquid light state
universe to the crystal of time the time
Adam The Fifth Dimension and the physics
of Love synchronicity he further
explores the interplay between mind body
and spirit and sheds light on the
fascinating concept of a Vortex of
creation although the author's theories
may not be explicitly outlined in this
video the sheer volume of research and
consideration he has put into his ideas
is worthy of recognition and merits a
place among the honorable mentions it is
highly recommended to go view the
author's video and delve into this
thought-provoking idea in the playlist
jumping continuity Theory from Daniel
Varga and Chris Leto's Theory
Consciousness resonates and octaves like
waves with an emphasis on the evolution
of morphological patterns these two
perspectives delve into the idea that
intricate designs and complex systems
arise from basic initial conditions
Chris employs the illustration of
cellular automata to encourage the
audience to Envision a universe governed
by fundamental fractal parameters such
as sound light and frequency he posits
that a structural parallel can be drawn
between the composition of atoms and
that of galaxies showcasing the
Simplicity that underlies seemingly
complex phenomena a unified theory of
thermodynamics space-time in 2003 Guerra
became convinced that the prevailing
definition of heat was flawed in that it
was actually space-time itself despite
writing his ideas down and sending it to
several prominent physicists by email in
2009 its radical nature and the lack of
evidence hindered its credibility
however in 2018 a group of Chinese
scientists independently validated one
of guerra's predictions providing
evidence for his hypothesis in the video
the author comments on this experiment
presenting its implications as a basis
for a new model of space-time and a path
towards a unified field Theory
who are we where are we going by the
channel knowing Sperry presents a unique
perspective on the nature of
Consciousness proposing a dimensionless
mechanism at its core he posits that
point-centered processes are the driving
force behind all phenomena including the
expansion of the universe and that this
mechanism is a self-organizing
non-material Consciousness according to
the soft model this Consciousness
generates dimensional byproducts and
measurements that give rise to physical
emotional mental Soulful and spiritual
realities
the matter of space by Brian scipione
complex fields of invariant gauge Theory
and general relativity have long been a
challenge for physicists with the
current crisis in physics and our
limited understanding of the vast
majority of the matter and composition
in the universe the integration of these
theories with the standard model remains
a formidable task however Brian offers A
New Perspective on the conundrum by
delving into the basis for a potential
Theory which integrates general
relativity and quantum theory the author
discusses topics such as event
displacements black holes the nature of
gravity and the origins of time
easy solution to Consciousness by
innocence this video highlights the
Journey of Mark Psalms and Carl friston
who are prominent neuroscientists as
they delve into the realm of
thermodynamics information Theory and
computation their aim was to tackle the
persistent and challenging question of
Consciousness the video posits that
conscious experiences arise as feelings
serving as a means of guiding the body
to make informed decisions based on the
most favorable conditions the central
theme of the video is the hard problem
of Consciousness and how it can be
understood through the lens of the free
energy principle a concept that all
living systems abide by
Loop quantum gravity and field Theory by
Dr natarajan doctor in a renowned expert
in the field of group field Theory and
loop quantum gravity has graciously
taken it upon himself to provide a
Serene and sophisticated overview of the
work that has been done in this area
with breathtaking visual aids he
artfully weaves in narrative that exudes
tranquility and elegantly presents the
complex Topics in a manner that is
easily digestible
the infinity by James Soros in the video
the infinity unlimited James delves into
the question of whether existence and
non-existence coexist the author
meticulously explores four different
solutions in search of a compatibility
between these two seemingly opposing
Concepts the author reaches a remarkable
conclusion that the most fundamental
aspect of reality is actually the
concept of infinity itself this idea
suggests that the universe may be
inherently boundless both in terms of
existence and non-existence
intro to the quantum harmonic oscillator
by Richard Bale this video which is both
aesthetically pleasing and elegantly
presented provides a comprehensive
analysis of the evolution of the
harmonic oscillator it elegantly
illustrates how ideal binding forces
ranging from molecules and atoms to
entire systems are influenced by the
quantum harmonic oscillator the video
effectively uses this concept as a model
to demonstrate its practical
applications in the field of chemistry
and molecular Dynamics the analytic
solution is also given due consideration
and its significance in the overall
understanding of the harmonic
oscillators emphasized with its
captivating visuals and compelling
narration this video provides an
insightful and accessible explanation of
a complex subject that will be of great
interest to students of physics
chemistry and molecular Dynamics
lagrangian mechanics by physics fluency
many videos in the fields of mathematics
and science are notable for their
expertise in creating graphic
representations that are seamlessly
integrated into a cohesive narrative
this particular video stands out in its
ability to demonstrate the power of
visual aids and the explanation of
complex Concepts through its
presentation we are privileged to
witness the analytical solutions to a
system of differential equations that
have been derived through the process of
linearization the elegant solution is
then brought to life through the use of
vivid Graphics which illustrate the
implications of the solution and Its
Real World application this video also
delves into the intricacies of eigen
frequencies and vectors offering a
comprehensive examination of these key
Concepts the result is a breathtaking
solution for the pendulum problem and
serves as a beautiful example of a
thorough explanation brought to life
through visuals
sgtoe by Sonic gravity among the videos
exploring mathematics physics and
spirituality some take a more
unconventional approach offering
perspectives that are both unique and
profound one such video is Sonic
gravities the holographic principle of
the universe which delves into the wide
range of subjects that are often
considered disparate but are brought
together in a way that is both
insightful and captivating over the
course of the video the viewer has taken
on a journey that begins with the
spontaneous birth of particles and leads
to a complete understanding of the
holographic nature of the universe along
the way the viewer is introduced to a
variety of Concepts including black hole
Genesis time time dilation Consciousness
the identity of dark matter the god
equation that being the Einstein
Voorhees energy of mass equation dark
energy and even teleportation each of
these topics is treated as a necessary
node in a larger narrative which is
woven together to create a unified whole
to fully grasp the ideas presented in
the video one may require several weeks
if not months nevertheless the journey
is well worth the effort for it offers a
unique and insightful perspective on the
universe and our place within it
what is E8 good for by quantum gravity
research E8 is a group in mathematics
and physics known as the exceptional Lee
group of Dimension 248 it is one of the
largest and most exceptional of the lead
groups and has played a significant role
in the development of several branches
of physics and Mathematics including
String Theory Quantum field Theory and
algebraic geometry in physics E8 is
often associated with the symmetries of
the unified theory of the fundamental
forces and has been proposed as a
candidate for describing the structure
of the universe at its most fundamental
level quantum gravity research is a
fascinating field that delves into the
intricacies of Lee algebra's root
systems and their applications to the
symmetries of space-time the researchers
in this field have done a remarkable job
of presenting complex topics and in this
video is suggested in a manner that is
both digestible and engaging the
author's work have implications for
understanding of the standard model and
Grand unified theories and now for the
winners number one triadic idealism the
current prevailing view in answering the
composition of the universe is
physicalism however some say it falls
short in explaining Consciousness to
address this limitation the speaker
delves into the philosophy of
metaphysical idealism with the focus on
countering the decoherence problem in
idealism he argues that the reality of
the universe lies solely within the
realm of Minds the speaker guides us
through the criticism of idealism by
philosophers Moore and Russell and
explains why absolute idealism in the
form of pan psychic idealism is a
credible idea he highlights how this
perspective provides a unique and
compelling explanation for the nature of
Consciousness and the universe number
two time independent Solutions in
electrodynamics in this enlightening
Journey Sorenson expertly guides us
through the complexities of the time
independent Solutions in electrodynamics
with his vast knowledge and Mastery of
the subject he confidently navigates
their challenging equations in the field
and Source Expressions through his
guidance we gain a deeper understanding
of the intricacies of this field of
study at the end of this journey nud
Sorensen takes his time to discuss the
potential for growth and Improvement in
electrodynamics he sheds light on
opportunities that may lie ahead and
provides valuable insights into how the
field can be Advanced and optimized this
video offers a rare glimpse into the
mind of a knowledgeable expert in
electrodynamics and provides a
thought-provoking exploration of the
subject number three the space-time
metric in this wonderfully engaging
video dialect begins with a deceptively
simple inquiry how do we describe
distance while answer appears
straightforward the concept becomes
complex and more and more complex when
considered in relation to the coordinate
grid through a captivating Journey were
introduced to the fascinating world of
space-time cartography the speaker
presents a comprehensive geometric
interpretation of the space-time metric
which provides a deeper understanding of
the relationship between distance and
coordinate grids this video offers a
unique perspective on subjects and
provides a thought-provoking exploration
of the complexities of space-time number
four can math explain Consciousness The
elusive nature of Consciousness and its
underlying mechanisms have been a source
of mystery and Fascination for centuries
despite the observable behaviors of
conscious beings it remains unclear
whether these actions are indicative of
true Consciousness this raises a
multitude of ethical considerations
especially with machine learning and AI
of the various theories attempting to
shed light on the nature of
Consciousness there are only a handful
that utilize mathematical explanations
the idea that we can use patterns of
brain activity to understand the
workings of the mind is a tantalizing
one the astonishing hypothesis outlined
in integrated information Theory
provides us with a glimpse into the vast
potential of this field while it may not
offer a definitive answer it presents
rich and thought-provoking insight into
the direction of This research and the
steps that need to be taken in order to
unlock the secrets of consciousness
last but not least epnol in the
beginning this beautiful and captivating
presentation delves into the intricacies
of The Surreal numbers highlighting null
as a focal point it brings to light the
numerous underlying assumptions that
have been made in the realm of
mathematical Infinity with the narrator
holding a PhD in physics and a passion
for octonians and quaternions the
audience can only hope that the surreal
physics Channel continues to evolve not
only in its visual aesthetic but in its
ability to effortlessly communicate
complex technical concepts with Clarity
and elegance actually that wasn't last
and the following two are honorable
mentions Brilliance has come on board to
give 500 to both of these entrants and
they don't know this until now this is a
surprise special mention to professor
unzeker and to Tyler Goldstein what are
we talking about when we speak of a
theory of everything would we recognize
it if we were to discover it it's not
about a correct calculation or
observation but finding where to start
unsaker takes us through a series of
statements principally that physics has
indeed achieved plenty and this is
evidence that it's important unzeker
considers the position that g has no
meaning and it can be set to the plank
length numerical values have an
intrinsic purpose in nature and
therefore important to the progress of a
theory of everything he covers direct
the constants of the universe and
complex matrices Tyler Goldstein on the
other hand is developing a sentient
Singularity Theory and how a variety of
meaningful perspectives can be taken to
approach a unified theory fundamental to
his Insight is that someone exists at
least that you exist and others
therefore the inclusion of subjective
metaphysics is necessary to integrate in
hopes to rank order theories by their
fundamentality Tyler considers morality
and responsibility the lack of
cooperation in science and how this may
all work out in the end in conclusion
I'd like to reiterate my immense
gratitude for all those who took part in
this challenge this was thrilling
challenging obviously overwhelming at
times and above all a fantastic way to
connect with you as the audience of toe
also to cultivate a community which is
one of the major aspects that delineates
theories of everything the project from
Mere podcast channels and to Showcase
your fellow commenters Watchers
listeners to you thank you thank you
brilliant because it wouldn't be
possible without them in fact they said
you don't even need to put a sponsor
message we're just donating this money
so thank you brilliant thank you to you
for watching for listening for making
tow what it is for helping not only toe
get to the point where it could be but
helping other creators in proxy via this
contest via this challenge this
encouragement and a final note this is
just the beginning there are several
several several plans for the future
take care the podcast is now concluded
thank you for watching if you haven't
subscribed or clicked on that like
button now would be a great time to do
so as each subscribe and like helps
YouTube push this content to more people
also I recently found out that external
links count plenty toward the algorithm
which means that when you share on
Twitter on Facebook on Reddit
Etc it shows YouTube that people are
talking about this outside side of
YouTube which in turn greatly AIDS the
Distribution on YouTube as well if you'd
like to support more conversations like
this then do consider visiting
theoriesofeverything.org again it's
support from the sponsors and you that
allow me to work on Tow full time you
get early access to ad-free audio
episodes there as well every dollar
helps far more than you may think either
way your viewership is generosity enough
thank you
thank you foreign
[Music]